microsoft
has implemented a new woke word checker
this is this is in a new menu item
called grammar and refinements
in word which is the most popular word
processing program in the world
it doesn't check how you spell words it
doesn't check how you use
grammar
or punctuation it checks age bias
cultural bias ethnic slurs gender bias
gender neutral pronouns gender specific
language racial bias sexual orientation
bias and socioeconomic bias so if you
type in
mrs thatcher
referring to the iron lady mrs thatcher
did this in great britain
it will suggest that you change it to ms
thatcher
i suspect maggie thatcher's rolling in
her grave at the very thought
if you type in
the
phrase uttered by neil armstrong as he
took the first step onto the moon
one small step for a man one giant leap
for mankind it will suggest you change
it to
humankind you know humankind it's more
inclusive isn't it even though man is a
gender-neutral word in the beginning god
created man both male and female he
created them
no can't do that anymore we have to
change the first words on the moon
when you switch this tool on
the spelling mistakes are underlined in
red the grammar errors are underlined in
blue and inclusiveness issues are
underlined in purple
microsoft is a very woke company you
might remember some months ago microsoft
held a conference and they opened the
conference by by engaging in the liberal
liturgy of
of pretty much any woke trope you can
find they threw in everything but the
kitchen sink
hello and welcome to microsoft ignite
we've got a big day ahead and lots in
store for you
first we want to acknowledge that the
land where the microsoft campus is
situated was traditionally occupied by
the sammamish the duwamish the
snoqualmie the suquamish the muckleshoot
the snohomish the tulalip and other
coast salish peoples since time
immemorial a people that are still here
continuing to honor and bring to light
their ancient heritage
my name is alison wines i'm a senior
program manager in our developer tools
division i'm an asian white female with
dark brown hair wearing a red sleeveless
top
and i'm seth juarez program manager in
the ai platform group i'm a tall
hispanic male wearing a blue shirt khaki
pants
it goes on and on it really only gets
worse from there
slight side note you notice they never
ask themselves why this land was
occupied by all those groups of people
this land was occupied by the swamish
and the sashimi and the michael shoot
and the hooky hockey and they all it was
all occupied by all of you why
why was that is it because one group
took it from another group
well they were all occupying it at the
exact same time i don't think so i think
actually one group came in and took the
land from the group was there that was
there before and that was considered
perfectly fine and we have no problem
with it but then we came in and
took the land in some cases won it
through conquest sometimes bought it but
that's evil and terrible because it was
christendom that came in and did that
a digression
this is
a great threat to our political order
but it's not government people pushing
it it's not just big government
all right it's
corporation it's corporate power it's
technological power
it's not government but it's still
political
it still shapes our whole political
order how we understand ourselves how we
understand our relation to citizens how
we understand our relation to the state
this happens to be the subject of my
book speechless which i finished one
year ago today exactly
and thank you to everyone who bought
that made it a number one national
bestseller this is what republicans and
conservatives are going to need to fight
moving forward
this is not just about what big
government does
but it is political it's not just about
joe biden issuing some policy raising
taxes some executive order it's it's
about joe biden redefining martin luther
king day as george floyd day which is
essentially what he did it's about some
what corporation
encouraging you to say this and don't
say this it's about big tech explicitly
prohibiting you from saying certain
things and that reshapes all of it those
are very powerful political interests
and it is incumbent on any serious
conservative who wants to maintain
something resembling the traditional
american way of life to fight back
against all of it i'm so glad you liked
that clip
i thought it was good work
i thought it was pretty interesting i
it's look i'm with you is what i'm
saying we both appreciated that clip so
you gotta subscribe
you gotta ring that bell get those
notifications for all the new videos
that come out and head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review i
appreciate it we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you